تُطلق أوبر خدمة هليكوبتر
متميزة تتعهد بإيصالي إلى
المطار في غضون ثماني دقائق فقط ولكن بسعر
200 دولار هو هذا يستحق السعر
والوقت حتى أتمكن من أخذ uberx للذهاب إلى
الفندق الذي أريد الذهاب إليه في JFK و
سأصل إلى هناك في حوالي 40
دقيقة ، تبلغ تكلفة ركوب المروحية مائتين وخمسة
دولارات ، وتستغرق الرحلة ثماني دقائق ، ولكن
بحلول الوقت الذي ننتقل فيه إلى
مهبط طائرات الهليكوبتر ، يخبرني ذلك 11:45 وهو في
الواقع متأخر بخمس دقائق عن
مجرد ركوب السيارة
[موسيقى]
منذ حوالي 40 دقيقة
، نقترب الآن من
[الموسيقى] ،
فما الفرق بين uber
air و uber copter ، لذا فإن uber copter
هو المنتج المتاح الآن
بين مانهاتن السفلى وجون كينيدي بحيث
يمكنك حجزه ونحن الآن  الانفتاح
على جميع مستخدمي تطبيق uber و uber
air هو هذا المنتج المستقبلي
الذي سنطلقه بمجرد توفر هذه
الأنواع الجديدة من المركبات ، وبالتالي يمكنك
أن تتخيل أن
uber copter هو نوع من
الإصدار الأول لهذا المنتج المستقبلي.  القبعة هي في
الأساس ما نفكر فيه على أنه
متعدد الوسائط ، لذلك عندما فتحت التطبيق ،
رأيت أنه يمكنني ركوب 200 دولار في رحلة بطائرة هليكوبتر
أو يمكنني ركوب uberx الذي
يمكن أن يجعلني في نفس الوقت تقريبًا
وربما أقل مقابل 60 دولارًا فقط ، لذا يمكنك
تحدث قليلاً عن كيفية
تبرير تكلفة ذلك بالتأكيد ، لذلك نحن في
الواقع سنقوم فقط
بتقديم أو تشغيل خدمة المروحية
في فترة ما بعد الظهر خلال
الأوقات المزدحمة ، وبالتالي
فإننا نفتح نافذة التشغيل من الساعة الثانية إلى الخامسة أو الثانية إلى السادسة.
في أيام معينة ، لا نعرض سوى المروحية
كخيار لركابنا
عندما يوفر لك الوقت
الذي يمكن لتقنيتنا وراء الكواليس أن
تنسج معًا شبكة سياراتنا
على الأرض مع المركبات الجوية في هذه
الحالة المروحية بحيث يمكنك
الانتقال بسلاسة  من سيارة إلى
طائرة مروحية لإضافة سيارة للوصول إلى
الوجهة النهائية متسلسلة بالكامل
ومعرفة بتقنيتنا
خلف الكواليس